I'm about to rule the world
without your help the Mushroom Kingdom
will be annihilated
I fear nothing you're coming with us
we're best friends but are we
destroy the mushrooms
it is on like Donkey Kong
[Music]
Bowser is coming together we will stop
uh who's he
[Music]
space is amazing
yes this has been training him
I'm not threatened
[Applause]
you asked for it
come on
[Music]
Mario oh I got this no problem
you were gonna help me find my brother
Luigi there's a human do you know
think I know every human being with a
mustache wearing a magnetical outfit
with the letter of his first name on it
because I know
to the biggest fight of Our Lives
your brother has landed in the dark
lands they're under Bowser's control
hang on Luigi
is
[Music]